what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg's pointing at you because you're
a secret scroll you son of a John how's
it going I am terrific sir how are you I'm
doing well oh I'm feeling good are you
feeling good I am feeling good and I'm
feeling authentic and original I am excited
to talk about secret Invasion guys we would
love it if you could do the deed of leaving a
like if you end up enjoying this video anyway
we got a bunch of Turners coming out this week
so subscribe and click that notification Bell
because trailers Galore apparently all to
get on that Mario release let's do this
thank you
sure Nicholas since you've
been gone I could breathe
for the first time you've gotten much worse
oh you think I came back [Music]
why have you been gone you're in no shape
for this fight that lies before us old friend
yeah graphic awesome
this is personal very few of us know about
the wars fought in the shadows
that have raged on this planet
do you feel responsible Clark
yes sir where are the Avengers a question this
war is one I have to fight alone patchless Fury
man the music in this wanted man on the planet
you don't know what they have planned for you
the Great Neck Fury wow
God damn jeez
today
one last fight oh [__] cool they do it oh
excited to talk about this yeah did you catch
Quake I caught Quake she was all over this trailer
just quaking everything left and right Agents of
Shield quick testing she really just kind of took
the stage and didn't give anybody else a chance
to speak or be featured at all like I don't
know what the show's even about no one does
John no alrighty guys well I love the trailer for
this it felt very cold and Atmospheric from the
first trailer to this one you just get this like
in the words of John Humphrey this percolating
dread that's right it's the whole atmosphere my
phrase I love it because this feels very serious
harkenies at the times of something like Captain
America Winter Soldier but with more of a Sci-Fi
angle to it that has that Invasion of the Body
Snatchers quality as well and you get this like
sense of like a brimming War everywhere around us
we were talking on the live stream the other day I
was getting like a cold war flare to it like we're
on the verge of something terrible going down and
we need to be on the lookout I love the way it's
shot because throughout the whole cinematography
there's constantly this like greenish landscape
and tint to it representing the Scrolls
that's hiding and playing filmmaking 101 right
it's the observation that's why I went to a film
School online at Phoenix and University yeah it's
working 17 yeah I was able to say [__] like
that John that's right it's beautiful you know
especially with Nick Fury finally getting his
own Standalone his own story to have a standalone
property it's just fun looking at it because you
know when this is clearly more picking up as
a sequel from the events of what happened from
Captain Marvel to now while factoring in some
other random [__] that's occurred since then
you know from what we were reading did you read
the Vanity Fair article I did okay good let's
just recite everything from there this I speed
read it good I slow Reddit so between the two
of us between the two of us we should be able to
find Common Ground while talking about it Samuel
Jackson was kind of divulging a lot that you
know Emilia Clarke's character is going to be
the daughter of Talos Gaia her character was a
little girl featured in Captain Marvel now that
you know the time has passed the Scrolls have been
expecting to have a home by now because that was
one of Nick Fury's promise he hasn't been able to
uphold that promise obviously so now you got kind
of these like factions of Scrolls where it feels
like some Scrolls they just want to like rise at
the surface and and find and take take the planet
one impression you get and the other's like no
there's got to be a peaceful calm there's got to
be like a pacifistic way of going about this we're
gonna get something really personal between Talos
and Gaia because Gaia is more on the rebellious
end of it and then you got Nick Fury who I get the
sense here you'll get more of like a vulnerable
quality to him versus the more Stern strong in
command I feel like he's gonna rise back into
that character over the course of the series yeah
absolutely and I think that'll be a really fun and
interesting thing to see because I believe he is
supposed to be in the Marvels to some capacity so
yeah it ruins that this is not one last time then
oh no well you know I mean what's one last time
when we could be making those big bucks on a big
weekend and setting records uh but yeah no no I
like I love the idea of actually zooming in on him
and giving him a journey that yeah will certainly
be physical and have a huge world-rending stakes
and all that stuff but that will too uh probably
yeah give him an opportunity to have his like
closest people Maria Hill and Talos in this
struggle at least you know by his side again who
he's been estranged from for so long while he's
been off world doing whatever he's been doing
and uh and yeah it would be nice to see some of
Samuel L Jackson's actual like acting chops I
mean we know he can be commanding as Nick Fury
but to you know get some of the pathos would be a
nice thing as well and uh yeah like Emilia Clarke
like I'm rooting for this to be the time that she
really like fully brings me into a character and
I feel like this whole show has a great amount
of potential because you know there have been
both times leading with just this tone and this
paranoia and the idea that anyone could be you
know your enemy hiding right next to you and
that's very relevant to the here and now but
that's also easily you know lending to those Cold
Cold War themes and flavors that they're bringing
in who do you trust John I don't trust anybody
but Nick they just gotta have a really funny scene
where everyone's just transforming left and right
yes and then they're all transforming into you
know Baskin Robbins Scott Lang or something like
that I think what was so cool about especially
this one though is you there is a sense of true
Peril and Desperation another one of John's words
sure you had it John enough you start to pick
up on some words that John says and then this
paranoia where now I feel so harsh new words yes I
gotta stop saying sure all the time to agree with
things well it just seems like there's a lot of
emotional weight you know one of my words because
there's a lot of emotional heft throughout it and
I love this sense of paranoia that it's constantly
spread throughout here you know so I think it's
I think it's really cool because it feels less
like winter soldier but more like a tinker Taylor
Soldier spots that is a great Touchstone actually
because I think the one of the creators said
like aside from you know TV of recent note that
you know Echoes these kinds of themes uh uh John
Kare the author's last name is karei and he wrote
Tinker Taylor Soldier spies oh really a bunch of
other yeah novels oh how funny yeah spy Espionage
tales and whatnot so yeah that's definitely in
this okay mixture here and this too to piggyback
off the Captain America thing like it it doesn't
uh it almost feels to like a more substantial
version of what Falcon in the Winter Soldier was
trying to bring us with the whole flag Smashers
thing in a way I mean there's also like a this
almost reminds me too of like a dark episode of
Doctor Who in trying to find a new home and some
of them are just tired of waiting and tired of the
bureaucracy and tired of the unanswered promises
and yeah now you have this group fracturing and
I I hope that they take the opportunity to make
this you know like an actual piece of allegorical
fiction not just like a fun adventure with these
flavors wrapped you know shrink wrapped on top
you want to see how it ties into the Multiverse
of saga that's what matters most to me John well
if they bring a quake maybe it will I think
it will you know finally get the answer about
where Agents of Shield Sands and all this well
what did you guys think about this trailer for
secret Invasion did we do all right without koi
being here because that was the pressure how bad
did we fail how bad did we fail koi could tell us
that guy what the Groot arm is we're just Talos
and Maria Hill and koi is out there off world just
floating around yeah I think Olivia Coleman's her
name yes I think she's a red herring that's
why they put her in red symbolism well thank
you what did you think leave your thoughts and
predictions down below do you think Talos will
die hashtag Talos dead no hey let's shout out
some all right Adrian Tims killer Kendrick noise
righteous Ryan Baines ribbed for your pleasure
Rob Frawley II Justice Jeffrey Robinson righteous
real nagas barf and Barca Fano one jellicle
jespreet Boulevard riffing with Roberto Engelman
holy Heather gear ignites the Ian Simon shout
the Songhai Glover Jesus it's Jacob Neptune
kooky Kayla the king awesome as always Alan Ling
lovely Logan Burton cook it in the kitchen here
so it sounds effervescent Eric Hans 39.
kite flying with naughty Nick X dirty
Dijon January juicy Juan Longoria girthy
Gail Ferguson clapping Cliff Rodriguez
masturbatori Master T jump on John the goat
looking bastards Lorenzo Baxter doing stuff
differently same most tenacious Marco Tunstall
loquacious and hellacious Lauren American Horse so
effin simply faded run kick Rogue Cree writing
essays with sj-94 just match Johnston Martin
running backwards Rosie Beatty call me Colin penis
Jesus and Sicily Philip K Smith Jr [Laughter]
join Scientology Jen Smith
milk and ladies Melanie LeBlanc
you know I already did it it's the job good
theme today John I hope other people picked
up on it uh you know I didn't dictate what
the subject matter would be just what the
game parameters could be so you know it's it's
every month that's that's the thing it's it's
a new experience you never know what's
coming off these domes except a couple
of you who we might have repeated over time
yeah righteous alrighty guys thanks for being